Salut, aujourd'hui on est dimanche c'est donc le jour de l'explication de la semaine
Alors, cette explication elle va se passer en 2 temps, c'est à dire que dans un 1er temps vous allez faire ce que je vais vous dire
vous allez vivre vous même l'expérience, je vais vous mentaliser à travers la caméra
Comme les vidéos que je faisais en 2015 la mentalisation à travers la caméra
et ensuite, pour que vous vous puissiez le refaire à d'autres personnes,
vous aurez juste à refaire exactement ce que j'ai dit sans changer une seule ligne, sans changer un seul mot
et vous verrez ça fonctionnera super bien, de la même manière.
Cette mentalisation va se baser sur l'imagination, j'espère que vous en avez.
Vous allez imaginer que devant vous, il y a un grand saladier
Un gros saladier là, juste là comme ça.
Avec pleins de pièces de 10 centimes à l'intérieur, il est rempli de pièces de 10 centimes
Je ne sais pas pourquoi vous avez mis les pièces de 10 centimes là dedans,
mais en tout cas, dans votre imaginaire, ce saladier est rempli de pièces de 10 centimes
Vous allez plonger votre main dans ce saladier et en prendre une petite poignée
Pas beaucoup, quelques unes en fait, il faut qu'il y en ait quelques unes dans votre main
Dans l'imaginaire de votre main.
Ouvrez la main dans votre esprit et comptez le nombre de pièces qu'il y a, y en a peut être 2, y en a peut être 7, peut être 5 je n'en sais rien
Vous déterminez ce chiffre là maintenant et vous calculez combien ça vous fait.
Donc si vous avez 4 pièces, ça vous fait 40 centimes
Si vous avez pris beaucoup de pièces, ce qui m'étonnerais, c'est pas trop conseillé,
mais genre 12 pièces, ça vous fait 120 centimes par exemple donc calculez la somme que vous avez pris dans le saladier
et enfin, petite opération mathématique, (oui vous pouvez calculer un petit peu dans le lit le dimanche matin)
vous allez retrancher de votre somme d'argent le nombre de pièces que vous avez
c'est à dire que si vous avez pris 8 pièces, vous faites 80 centimes moins 8
puisque vous avez 80 centimes dans les mains moins les 8 pièces donc vous faites ça
Je vous laisse un tout petit peu de temps pour le faire
Vous soustrayez à la somme de l'argent que vous avez dans les mains le nombre de pièces que vous avez pris dans le saladier
Vous avez maintenant un nombre en tête, ce nombre là il est à vous, il vous appartient évidemment
On va faire un petit peu de numérologie avec ce nombre là, on va le réduire en un seul chiffre donc vous allez le réduire
Si vous ne savez pas ce que c'est réduire un nombre, c'est additionner les chiffres qui le composent
Par exemple, si je réduis 161, je vais faire 1+6+1
Si je réduis 17, je vais faire 1+7=8
Je pense que c'est assez clair, c'est ce qu'on appelle une réduction en numérologie donc réduisez votre nombre
Maintenant vous avez un résultat en tête, un résultat à vous qui va déterminer ce que vous allez faire aujourd'hui, de ce dimanche
ça va déterminer une action et une seule, les correspondances vont apparaître ici à l'écran
Voilà, je les fais apparaître ici devant moi, mettez votre doigts sur celle qui correspond à votre chiffre à vous
Faites le vraiment, vous mettez votre doigt sur celle qui correspond à votre choix à vous
et c'est cette action que vous allez faire aujourd'hui, ce dimanche matin.
J'enlève toutes les autres, vous allez simplement vous abonnez à la chaine
Et oui c'est sûr puisque vous aviez le doigt dessus il y a 1 seconde
Alors, c'est ouf de se faire mentaliser en vidéo ou pas
Et comme j'ai dit en vidéo mais de toute manière vous le savez,
le dimanche c'est quelque chose que vous pouvez reproduire pour bluffer les gens,
peut être au repas de famille que vous avez dans une heure, peut être ce soir ou dans la semaine
Vous allez pouvoir faire ce que je vous ai fait moi pour ça c'est très simple
Vous suivez la même procédure, vous utilisez les mêmes mots que moi et pour le final, c'est vous qui décidez
ou vous faites une petite fiche cartonnée comme moi j'ai fait
et donc vous avez bien compris que je vous ai initié à un petit forçage mathématique qui abouti forcément sur le 9
ou vous pouvez prédire à l'avance le résultat ou prédire à l'avance la correspondance sur laquelle il tomberait
après c'est vous qui voyez, je vous laisse imaginer ça, vous vous faites plaisir
Ce qui me ferait encore plus plaisir d'ailleurs c'est que dans les commentaires,
vous me racontiez ce qui se passe, ce qui c'est passé, comment vous l'avez mis en scène, qu'elles ont été les réactions de vos amis
Racontez moi ça, j'adore ça vous lire
J'espère que cette petite idée vous a plu et que de fait cette vidéo vous a plu
Si c'est le cas, n'hésitez pas, partagez la, laissez un petit pouce en l'air,
abonnez vous surtout à cette chaîne et faites en sorte que la terre entière s'abonne à la chaîne.
Et sinon je vous donne rendez-vous dans toutes les vidéos mais aussi sur scène le 22 février pour les "Hallucinations collectives"
C'est la première fois que je fais une vidéo dehors au milieu des gens et c'était très intimidant pour moi de parler
alors qu'il y a des gens qui passent de partout, on me regarde comme un ouf vous parler dans la caméra.
Quand même ça caille.
Rendez-vous demain à 17h pour le prochain mental vlog. Tchao.